hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be video all about dr. strange how
he figures into the MCU timeline right
now
Avengers Infinity Ward the time gem in
why I think he in spider-man are gonna
be like the two biggest Marvel
characters for like the next ten years
after infinity war so you've seen all
the Marvel movies you've been following
the timeline you've seen Doctor Strange
you know the doctor Strange's sanctum
sanctorum is in New York City so a lot
of you are wondering where was Doctor
Strange when all this stuff was
happening where was he during the Battle
of New York Winter Soldier name-dropped
him Sitwell said that he was on hydras
list of potential threats so what's
going on why haven't we seen him why
haven't the other Avengers learned about
him yet so this is really funny you guys
will appreciate this so everybody always
notices the similarities between Doctor
Strange and Iron Man in the comics they
kind of look like each other now modern
artists have kind of separated them like
you know mustache Bros for life look how
similar they look just a few more white
streaks and dr. Strange's hair like he
shows the ravages of time so it seems
like what the movies are going to do in
that same idea is that they're going to
say that dr. strange like the events of
dr. Strange's life have been happening
concurrently with the phase 1 phase 2
phase 3 timeline so that when we head
into Avengers infinity war he's already
become the sorcerer supreme he's already
got the eye of agamotto he is good to go
so think about Iron Man 1 and what
happened when Iron Man crawled his way
out of that cave made the Iron Man mark
1 suit that's about the time Doctor
Strange is gonna be having his accident
where his hands get crushed he
encounters the ancient one and has been
training as sorcerer supreme this whole
time while all this other Avengers
timeline stuff has been happening so
during the Battle of New York he's in
training during Avengers age of Ultron
he's in training that is a really easy
way to explain why he was not around to
help if he was that powerful and
somebody like Ultron came along of
course he would probably help out if he
could especially if he lives down the
street from the Avengers tower so it's
just a really easy way to explain what's
been going on this whole time and why he
hasn't been present and if you haven't
seen it I'll put a link in the
description but I posted
dr. strange villains trailer video where
talks about Baron Mordo cassellius Maz
Nicholson's character in his grand plan
so what he wants to do is basically
collapse the multiverse in all of
existence like all the different
dimensions into one space so when you
think about dimensions you think about
one dimension to dimension three
dimension like we live in the third
dimension then you have the fourth
dimension which is like all of space and
time we're in like third dimensional
beings like us would just experience
everything that had ever existed every
possibility all at the same time which
is why I think that we're going to see
the time gem and dr. strange because
he's gonna see all these different
possibilities
all these different times all these
different dimensions and it's gonna be
like this big i opening experience for
the marvel universe like we've seen the
galaxy like we've had guardians of the
galaxy
so we've seen aliens other planets big
cosmic threats but now dr. strange is
going to be like the guy to walk into
the Avengers and tell Tony Stark look
you're a man of science I understand
that magic is just science that you
haven't explained yet look at all these
different possibilities all these
different dimensions he's gonna like
blow Tony Stark's mind I can't wait to
see Doctor Strange try to explain
multiple dimensions Dormammu to Tony
Stark who I think is gonna be the big
bad after Thanos you have a guy like
Heimdall who can pinpoint almost anybody
in the third dimension like he has the
ability to see almost everything that
exists in their dimension like he could
spot anybody no matter where they are
unless they have abilities like Loki
that can mask detection but you get the
idea Heimdall can see almost everything
in our universe Doctor Strange collapses
that idea into like seeing all across
the multiverse at the same time so you
have all these other threats all the
terrors that exist between dimensions
like if you know about the cancer verse
in Marvel it's basically like a darkest
timeline universe where everything is
just way way worse than it is in our
universe and it tries to encroach on our
universe that's where we get into Doctor
Strange Time gem stuff which is why I
think that that's gonna be a bigger deal
and phase four because it's a really big
concept like we're just dealing with
stuff in our universe so I'll be really
interested to see like how Doctor
Strange collapses all that and then
explains it to the other
Avengers and then they'll have like that
Iron Man 3 post-credits scene where dr.
strange is the counselor and Tony Stark
is on the couch just being like how do
we deal with this man
I don't know maybe there's some
unresolved issues from my childhood that
was actually one of my more favorite
Marvel post-credit scenes it was a very
science bros post-credits scene where
banner wakes up and he's like I'm sorry
I'm not I'm not that kind of doctor I
could totally see them doing a version
of that with Doctor Strange I'm sorry
Tony I'm also not that kind of doctor
but you can see how the time Jem is just
a really easy way to explain all of
these different realities existing
simultaneously in why Doctor Strange has
not been around this whole time he has
been in training so he has been away so
he doesn't really come back to the
sanctum sanctorum till after Avengers
age of Ultron as we head into infinity
war but here's an even bigger idea so
going into phase 4 like we're still
closing down phase 3 the end of that is
going to be infinity war the ant-man in
the wasp movie so going forward into
phase 4 a lot of actors are nearing the
end of their contract so what I think
that they're trying to do is turn Doctor
Strange into like the new Iron Man type
character like the character that it's
all built around and kind of at the
other end of the spectrum around the
Spider Man character because Spider Man
is like the in for everybody who's
seeing this for the first time like the
casual audience core who's like I don't
know who Dormammu is what's an infinity
gem like think about how many people
have absolutely no idea what's going on
it kind of makes your brain hurt a
little bit but I can see going into
phase 4 like they have all these new
characters that they're introducing how
Spider Man still becomes like the
biggest character ever one mostly
because he's always been the biggest
character behind Batman they're like in
the pantheon of popular comic book
characters Spider Man
worldwide is like the most popular
character ever next to Batman so no
matter what happens in the movies I
always see the Spider Man movies as
making more money than the other big
movies you know maybe not Avengers but
still Spider Man gonna be huge so it
makes sense that they would frame a lot
of this MCU context going forward like
oh my God look at all this crazy stuff
that's happening around his perspective
as well as conversely Doctor Strange
because he's the guy that explains
everything and sees all these different
possibilities
spider-man's like the
new every man character like I'm just
trying to do what's right trying to
figure all this crazy stuff out and dr.
strange is more of like the morally gray
character who's in the know like he
knows about such terrible things that
are happening so he has to make very
morally grey calls but that kind of gets
into Illuminati territory I'll be really
interested to see if they ever try to do
Illuminati in the Marvel movies but let
me know in the comments who do you feel
like is gonna be Marvel's biggest
character going into phase four not in
the context of the story but just in
general I feel like spider-man is gonna
be that guy like he's gonna be the easy
end for everyone who doesn't understand
comics doesn't read comics and he's one
of the most fun characters and that's
kind of like the whole core operating
principle of the Marvel movies is that
they are fun even though they twist you
up in very terrible ways so spider-man
gonna be a huge deal going forward so
you can see why he is such a high
priority for Marvel right now that they
nail it right now just such an important
thing going for for like the next ten
years
again hype it's a little early to be
talking about phase four stuff just
because we haven't even gotten infinity
war yet but what's gonna happen later
this weekend they'll probably some more
spider-man there'll be some more DC
stuff they were like a bunch of rumors
that came out there's a rumor that DC is
working on an HBO show I don't know
whether to believe it or not so I'll do
a little investigating maybe I'll do a
video about it so be sure to subscribe
to get that stuff there's a new round of
the Marvel giveaway - all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video it's at $30 Amazon
card just for the value of the Captain
America Civil War blu-ray so probably
gonna do a new Flash movie video later
tonight because the rumor is is that the
Rogues are gonna be the big villain to
that well you guys wait for that to post
you can click here to watch Vin Diesel
and James Gunn fangirl all over
guardians of the galaxy - and explain a
little bit of the plot and you can click
here for that funny Thor Ragnarok
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight